an overseas trip by house speaker nancy
pelosi is causing big friction with
china this morning she has just left
taiwan's capital after visiting the
national legislature and meeting with
the country's president the move has
upset china which considers taiwan to be
a rogue province it is responding with
military exercises around the island
nation our adam yamaguchi is there
good morning speaker nancy pelosi just
wrapped up a whirlwind but potentially
consequential visit to taiwan in the
face of threats from china she struck a
defiant tone and emphasized that america
would not abandon its commitment to
taiwan
america's determination to preserve
democracy here in taiwan and around the
world
remains ironclad
meeting with taiwanese president saint
nguyen
pelosi became the most senior u.s
official to visit taiwan in 25 years
the chinese foreign ministry called her
trip a complete farce warning that those
who offend china will be punished
shortly after the speaker landed china
announced plans for live fire military
drills and water surrounding taiwan a
move the taiwanese said demonstrates an
intention to destroy regional peace
what matters to us
is that we salute the successes of
taiwan
we work together for the security of
taiwan
china claims the island as its territory
and opposes any engagement by taiwanese
officials with foreign governments
pelosi's last stop in taiwan was the
museum of human rights
this is significant because human rights
is something that is near and dear to
her heart she first sort of made a big
name for herself in tiananmen square in
in china many many years ago this is
clearly a message
but on the streets of taipei some locals
expressed concern about how the visit
will impact them
these two great countries fighting for
power he says taiwan is stuck in the
middle taiwan is a small country we have
to try to survive
what happens tomorrow and beyond is the
question many here are now asking
will this highly scrutinized visit by
the speaker be worth the potential
consequences or punishment that china
may decide to deal out to taiwan
for cbs mornings adam yamaguchi taipei